théberge n'avez vous donc de
l'association des véhicules électriques
du québec 2e tour la grosse boule oui
bonjour si un jour elle avait déjà perdu
20 points parce que vous répondiez pas
la bonne réponse des nobles
on a dit là j'ai tardé vous truquez mais
bien passé noir franchement la zac des
étudiants de vendredi vous et vous
écouter
bon écoute et voici la question va
l'affiché vous avez pas besoin d'écouter
le besoin de lire refusez-vous
finalement voilà quelle est la taxe
minimale en norvège sur un véhicule
possédant un moteur à combustion ici on
offre des subventions à l'achat d'accord
en norvège on dit pas question
d'impliquer l'argent des contribuables
ou des fonds de du carbone là dedans on
va demander aux gens de payer si
j'achète encore un de ces vieux
véhicules avec moteur à combustion
polluantes qui sent mauvais alors est-ce
que c'est 5000 dollars en taxe minimale
sur un véhicule vieux genre qu'on impose
la place à sammy est ce que c b dix
mille dollars
est ce que c'est c'est 15 mille dollars
mon dieu
ou est ce que c'est des 20000 dollars
pays qui veut avoir tous les véhicules
électriques d'ici quelques années c'est
un pays qui produit du pétrole aussi et
du gaz attendez là où ça c'est pas
évident c'est pas évident on offre aux
quais treize mille dollars en
subventions un automobiliste aux
québécois alors est-ce qu'on va taxer
15000 dollars en norvège est ce que ça
va être si la bonne réponse
est-ce que ça va être bon y a pas aucune
de ces pensionnats pas parce que
dans un pays où il ya du réseau français
quelque part ce qu'il est vendeur de
mauvaise réponse je donnerai pas de
l'usl est vrai qu'avec samir ou tentez
votre chance
on va aller sur le à 5000 $ de taxes
pour juste pour m alors on y va on va
aller sur un peu comme le jeu du pendu
allait tomber tous les deux regardez la
réponse c'est qu'à metz du fric à temps
là ils ont commis deux véhicules
électriques maintenant bah écoutez c'est
la moitié des véhicules à ce moment
qu'ils sont des véhicules électriques
sont vendus mais que c'est un peu faire
la leçon du côté de la norvège
on continue à produire du pétrole à être
très à bénéficier de sa et en même temps
pénalise les gens chez nous on veut bien
paraître à la maison met en avant notre
pétrole ailleurs chose est certaine
c'est bien conduire en norvège coûte
plus cher qu'ici c'est la boxe et la
moyenne là alors écoutez on a quelqu'un
que qui est un invité spécial de samir
ben jaffar cette semaine et vous à nu le
présentez vous l'avez rencontrée à
personne nous aidez les à son
laboratoire
oui il s'agit maintenant d'une vedette
des médias puisqu'on le connaît il a
passé à quelques émissions de télévision
karim zaghib qui est directeur du centre
d'excellence à l'électrification des
transports à hydro québec et il y a de
remporter un prix important je vous
laisse tous les deux discuter on va tous
discuter avec toi donc karim il est
jeune on nous appelle karim bonjour donc
c'est un homme qui est très accessible
oui oui j'ai eu l'occasion d'aller
visiter quand même avoir un là où il ya
le centre d'excel de centres
d'excellence en électrification des
transports c'est ça et il faut 15
d'énergie et stockage d'énergie les
batteries oui donc karim commandes
présenter karim il est récipiendaire du
prix lionel boulet s'est il le prix
lionel boulet c'est l'un des prises de
l'un des prix scientifiques que rome et
le gouvernement du québec chaque année à
un scientifique ou un groupe de
scientifiques karim il est spécialisé
aussi dans les batteries et de batteries
lithium et qui dit batterie lithium il
faut se rappeler que cette année le prix
nobel de chimie a été remis à deux
chercheurs un japonais un américain qui
sont spécialisés dans le domaine et dans
l'un d'eux et 1 2 il va travailler avec
moi parce qu'un essieu mais bon oui
c'est ça parce que karim a fait un
passage au japon c'est de comprendre
exactement ça c'était il faut il ya
beaucoup de choses à dire à propos
duquel on va vous laisser donner à
monsieur karim l'a écouté merci de
l'invitation je suis oui je remercie
beaucoup le québec qui est le
gouvernement du québec pour le prix
lionel boulet et lionel baud lycée le
fondateur de la croix juillet le centre
de recherche au québec et c'est un
honneur aussi travailler ici aussi c'est
moi je suis toujours ici devant les
caméras mais j'ai une équipe qui
travaille que moi les gens qui
travaillent dans l'ombre donc d'une
équipe à shawinigan qui bavent à rennes
est une équipe en france et le
développement des batteries lithium-ion
bakhit solide il ya peu de gens qui
savent que hydro québec aujourd'hui
c'est la seule compagnie oman ont
parcouru la ville du nom qui a centres
de recherche et les batteries la
recherche du développement de batteries
ça commençait dans cette place depuis
1967 et aujourd'hui j'y vis toujours
peut-être avec une fierté aujourd'hui
est pas un téléphone portable ou un
ordinateur ou une voiture électrique ou
moins à l'intérieur d'une batterie un
élément qui est breveté par hydro québec
je peux vous faire de pub mais je pense
que tu es cela vous a battu au fil
d'arrivée 1 ça fait cinq ans que ça vous
y travaillez donc je fais des blagues
évidemment est ce que quand vous parlez
du des applications qu'on retrouve comme
ça sur le marché par tous ces quelques
probablement insoupçonnées on ne sait
pas qu'un consommateur
que saviez que ça a été fait chez vous
et tout peut que vous y avez en main à
la pâte
si on voit tout à l'heure il parlait de
prix john goodenough mais peu connu le
brevet de base qui a été breveté
moi je t'ai
mais il reconnaît que le cnrs qui montre
la conception d'une batterie lithium-ion
et la conception de la batterie tôt
solide ça a été breveté par hydro québec
qui par le service monsieur john godina
qui on travaille depuis 25 ans ces
récepteurs de duperie prix nobel en
chimie
c'est que le rôle d'hydro-québec nous
notre rôle c'est de faire la recherche
et développement et on s'associe avec le
manufacturier
si vous prenez l'exemple de tesla oui
l'exemple de tesla c'est un bon exemple
mais la batterie de tests classe a été
développé par par nationale par les
japonais et la compagnie qui à
développer et à commercialiser la
première batterie lithium-ion
si sony donc juste la conception que 10
fois si mal connu witi cela elle est
l'amie un moteur électrique avec des
batteries de panasonic avec un habitant
mais dix fois on oublie que le crédit et
il appartient à des compagnies
japonaises ont fait la commercialisation
et le brevet de base de lithium ion
comme je dis ça a été breveté en 79 par
hydro-québec le service et monsieur john
goodenough si le premier quart a mené la
la la la cathode de quatre vols donc
hydro québec nous un autre qu'on appelle
ça le core business c'est plus la r&d
développer le matériau chercher
aujourd'hui on est en cela un
gouvernement business il ya
investissement québec il ya toute une
stratégie pour développer une filiale
filiale d'hydro-québec avec une
stratégie de nos ressources naturelles
un écosystème québécois quand même il
faut pas qu'on oublie on a des bons
universités québécoises
on peut les comparer terre la boston au
sel silicon valley et je pense que nous
pouvons mettre le québec sur une belle
carte pour au futur pour des usines et
on est capable de concurrence y est
d'autres comme tesla autres à travers le
mans monsieur karim qu'est ce que votre
batterie va changer parce que je crois
comprendre qu'il est beaucoup plus petit
et qu'elle nécessitera peut-être moins
d'utilisation des métaux précieux
oui regardez juste pour corriger toutes
les batteries lithium-ion dont batteries
lithium-ion ou
batterie solide il n'y a pas des métaux
rares il n'y a pas des matériaux
précieux dans une batterie aujourd'hui
on l'appelle lithium-ion
il ya une anode et cathode électrique
dans l'ordre on utilise du cube
collector du graphite est dû un peu de
silicium dans la cathode on utilise du
cobalt du nickel et du manganèse et le
collector c'est de l'aluminium si on
fait la somme algébrique de tous ces
matériaux toutes ces ressources
naturelles existent au québec
et si on développe la filière des
ressources naturelles au québec c'est
que il faut faire la première la
deuxième transformation kyber pourquoi
parce qu'on à 100% notre énergie elle
est propre et coûte moins cher et aussi
on peut développer un écosystème avec un
fabricant de batteries qu'il ya une
stratégie géographique est proche
donc s'ils s'allient matériaux et ont
pensé au québec aussi si on est dans un
l'endroit politiquement stable et on a
accès de toutes les marchés le marché de
l'europe
le marché n'a milles du nord des etats
unis le mexique le marché de l'amérique
du sud est aussi là le marché de
l'asie-pacifique et ça ça nous donne
accès à peu près à 2 milliards de
clients et de plus on est proche aussi
des marchés on enterre you on a forgé un
chrysler est donc un à un en an annick
au système qui est impressionnant au
québec et on peut faire transformer nos
ressources naturelles
ici au québec vous avez ma question je
reviens juste une question très pratico
pratique les gens soupçonnent parfois
les batteries c'est toutes ces histoires
de batteries qui explose c'est dû à quoi
ou est ce que c'est juste une légende
urbaine où on envie tesla qui a explosé
ou une parité cela une voiture récemment
hissé à montréal pour l'été dernier il y
avait une voiture je pense hyundai qui a
explosé on sait pas pourquoi mais alors
est ce que est ce qu'il ya des choses
qui sont faites pour réduire ces risques
là aujourd'hui on a deux types de
lithium-ion
on n'appelle ni commis à un mc anciens
cini qu'elle comporte aluminium qui sont
l'oxygène et on a des batteries
lithium-ion fer phosphate
aujourd'hui la majorité des voitures
électriques utilisent du nickel combourg
aluminium ou du nickel manganèse cobol
avec l'occident
est ce qu'aujourd'hui toutes les
batteries lithium-ion l'électrolyte
c'est électrique inflammable c'est comme
les sens en revanche on explique c'est
un triangle de feu on à l'oxygène on a
les sens et on al ahly m
la limite c'est quoi c'est le
court-circuit au l'accident les sens et
l'électrolyte inflammable et l'oxygène
vient de la cathode est oui oui à un
problème au niveau de la sécurité
tout le monde travaille sur la spree
mais en revanche il faut pas avoir peur
lorsqu'on conduit une voiture électrique
aujourd'hui parce qu'on utilise qu'on
appelle ça des batteries management
system excusez-moi mômes au monde et
citant deux histoires de batterie de
gestion de ses protégés et on fait aussi
sûr qu'il ya liquide de refroidissement
en de maintenir toujours la température
et on met la batterie dans une cage
vraiment prête membres l'inde et donc
les risques et peut aimer en revanche
nous nous dit bhl on a déjà développé
des batteries sécuritaire avec le fer
phosphate de fer phosphate donc il ya
pas de risque mais en revanche densité
d'énergie au niveau lithium-ion et à 25%
moins nous on veut changer la trilogie
au complet ça veut dire que dalle et de
la batterie lithium-ion à une batterie
tout solide
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que la
nôtre la cathode est l'e.coli elle est
solide
tout ces gens qui envoient plus de
problème de feu est en revanche on va
augmenter la densité d'énergie augmenter
la densité d'énergie c'est quoi
aujourd'hui
la densité d'énergie aller de 250 watts
heure par kilogramme
on veut aller vers 500 watts par
kilogramme ça veut dire quoi que la
danse et d'énergie ça veut dire on va
augmenter l'autonomie
mais si on augmente l'autonomie ont valu
à peu près de 400 à 800 km une fois
qu'on arrive à 800 kilomètres donc on
n'aura pas à tout en charger la batterie
talent réel problème du conte donnions
dès qu'on dit le problème des
installations dans un appartement
donc on vendait en est aussi le prix ce
que nous
aujourd'hui le prix d'une batterie
lithium-ion au niveau kilowattheures en
parlant près de 200 à 220 les curateurs
nous on veut réduire le prix de cette
batterie parce que cette batterie
elles demandent pas beaucoup d'énergie
ne demande pas beaucoup d'étapes de
fabrication on veut lui versant dollars
le kilowattheure est à 100 $
kilowattheures par pac
on n'aura pas besoin de subventions et
le prix de la voiture électrique il se
rapproche de la voiture à essence un
sens
est-ce que vous avez un véhicule
électrique n'est pas la bonne question
regardez moi ça fait 25 ans la même avec
les batteries au plan là je roule
toujours avait il faut que je donne
l'exemple
aujourd'hui je roule avec une voiture
mitsubishi plugin qui fait 65 65 km
maintenant maintenant quand même une
bonne on pense au futur donc on a une
bonne qu'on appelle vie culturelle des
cultures ans on pense plutôt au niveau
du réseau parce que plus tard le client
il devient participatif et mon auto dans
quelques années je peux vendre
l'électricité à hydro québec
trente ont depuis quitté ma patrie comme
génératrice pour ma maison
ouais écoutez blaga vous auriez pu être
milliardaire et vous offrir en ce moment
une tesla
c'est pas le cas vous avez décidé de
travailler pour le secteur plaît oui
généralement aussi si je suis juste à
l'université ou à l'extérieur
la propriété intellectuelle appartient
50% aux chercheurs c'est le contraire
chez hydro-québec toute la propriété
intellectuelle à la rac1 à hydro-québec
se rassembler afin d'un patrimoine
québécois et on reçoit moins tous les
chercheurs ici on reçoit 0 $ sur ces
camps 550 inventions je peux être d'une
dizaine de millions jusqu'à 1 milliard
mais c'est une passion qui dit ban c'est
un choix personnel et
moi j'ai pris une direction avec mon
équipe de travailler pour les intérêts
supérieurs du québec d'hydro québec
l'humanité comme on dit en argent aille
dans lequel tout match au nord de
manille mais c'est le fait tous qui j'ai
un excellent salaire je dois avoir une
bonne retraite
et il le fait que j'essaierai de ramener
un grain pour guider l'humanité le
réchauffement de la planète on le sait
assez bien le côté fantastique on est
bien content vous avoir eu l'émission
vous a adopté parce qu'on vous appelle
monsieur monsieur karim haggui touché
très touché
merci beaucoup
alors c'était karim zaghib directeur du
centre d'excellence en électrification
des transports à etroubles québec va ce
merci nous avons ramené cet invité à
merci et adieu aussi de faire un travail
mais vivait venue des idées pendant
qu'il parlait nous aussi de propriété
intellectuelle on la donne 100% aux
patrons à radio canada sans recevoir un
sou il ya des choses communes
j'ai aussi mes minutes et m'est venue il
parle toujours de ses batteries moi j'ai
quelque chose de très simple alors
proposé je pense que ça peut être
étudiée c'est une pomme de terre
je pense ça pourrait servir de batteries
j'ai une idée comme ça sur laquelle je
travaille des pompes des fins oui alors
peu courants d'expérience aux primaires
avec la pomme de terre
on en fait nous devons vous étiez plus
avancées brp est reproduit pas été
producteur de poids de pommes de terre
c'est en fait il a failli me l'a fait
faillite à l'époque on peut pas vendre à
hydro québec
alors écoutez ça en feu je fais beaucoup
de farsi a rien de vrai dans ce que je
raconte
peut-être que la moitié est ce qu'il
reste une question oui la grosse boule
mais avant la grosse boule je sais que
j'ai perdu 20 points vous piaffez
d'impatience
la trouvaille aller à la grosse boule
puisque vous y tenez temps à perdre 50
boul ben elle vous en avez perdu
seulement en a 77 ans je pensais qu'on
avait perdu dès la première question on
a eu un bon il a changé de
compliqué pas les choses auraient perdu
30 seulement sur 50 jusqu'à maintenant
mais à 5 ans non sincère sur sa course à
relais à 70,70 très bien alors faisons
c'est qu'on a
j'aurais fait un bon avocat parce que
vous êtes confondues le troisième bull
grosse question alors aussi on la fiche
au début de 19 films de 2019
il y avait combien de véhicules
électriques et hybrides hybrides et
hybrides
photo action à l'hybride aussi inclure
ça sur la planète
est-ce que c'est moins de 6 millions
est-ce que cb - 2 5 millions ou est ce
que c'est c'est moins de 26 millions à
gérer pour nous attendait alors la
première fois j'ai entendu devait parler
d'avis que l'hybride toyota prius
quelque chose comme ça ça fait entre a
et b ça c'est quelque part entre a et b
selon chacun de nous prend à sorède
isséens californie il en avait 40
millions d'habitants a de plus qui sait
les japonnais de l'autre côté norvégien
de l'autre on va foncer sur les allées
pour le moins de vingt-six écoute
est-ce que je devrais l'allergie 10 est
d'accord d'origine française avec le
succès à lens il ya quelque chose en
alberta qui s'appelle borloo ce match
bof lost htc ce smash ten kate nash
tenbosse notre cher alors cela ils ont
découvert des ossements de deux nouveaux
nés
vous voulez nous dire qu on s'est lancé
on va regarder on va afficher la bonne
réponse c'est seulement passé
et la régie en reste 70 puisqu'elle n'a
participé qu'à la deux êtres à la
troisième question
la régie jouer avec nous il serait ce
que seulement en fin d'émission à propos
de batterie je ne sais pas ça m'est
revenue à l'idée je me suis rappelé qu'
est-ce que vous savez que car il nous
arrive dans son équipe sur l'histoire
des batteries stockage d'électricité ce
n'est pas juste les batteries de voiture
c'est aussi ils vont dans des
communautés où ils peuvent mettre des
containers comme une grosse batterie qui
peut fournir l'électricité à voir par
exemple chez les honore chez je connais
pas ces endroits touchés chez deux
communautés amérindiennes ils auront
fourni avec les listes avec le solaire
ils peuvent récupérer d'électricité dans
des batteries piles usagées sa banlieue
c'est vraiment dans leurs recherches il
ya une partie transport une partie
stockage dynamique et c'est la
décentralisation des infrastructures
c'est l'avenir
j'ai aimé le fait que ça qu'on peut
remettre l'électricité à hydro québec
là on peut faire du beurre électriques
quelque chose comme ça on peut nous nous
autres on peut aussi produire à acheter
allait acheter le nom le nom tout de
suite hubert l'hectare
je vous donne la libéralisation de
l'électricité s'était déjà fait ce côté
du maire hubert isation d'électricité
jeu on va vous laisser sur la dernière
vidéo c'est pour en savoir plus depuis
samedi on vous avait parlé d'une auto
qui explosait mais si vous allez voir on
a préparé cette vidéo sur les documents
qui accompagne cette émission rare il
pas à temps canada sur notre page web
on montre ça il ya six reportages en
tout je pense que le deuxième c'est
concernant ce véhicule automobile qui a
exposé exposé cet exposé - certes manqué
l'exploit oui c'est la deuxième voilà
une des passerelles enquête sur
l'explosion d'une voiture électrique
sans montréal dans un garage d'une
résidence
et heureusement qu'il y avait peu
heureusement qu'ils avaient person
ciment d'autres reportages de canada
doit résolument pour en mouvoir des
autos les autobus urbain à montréal il
ya un autobus son projet pilote l'
electrical récemment qui est sorti puis
à la dot d'autres nouvelles notamment la
chine qui s'impliquent qui pourrait
déjouer les projets de plusieurs et en
attendant les avions électriques comment
les rendre plus écologique c'est il ya
quelques semaines à peine où est la
finition on par les avions électriques
s'en viennent mais en attendant il va
falloir dépolluer le ciel il ya des gros
problèmes si je laisse à ce sujet là
voilà pour ceux qui veulent lire et
quand il ya aussi l'article café maryse
sur karim zaghib quand il a eu son prix
aussi oui je te fais passer l'image de
la presse qui est allé sur place mais on
peut trouver beaucoup d'informations
simplement on t'a pas son nom car il
arrive on vole on va rajouter vous avez
tout ce qu'il faut gouvernement du
québec
tout ce qu'il a reçu comme prix c'est
vraiment la route et récemment la
stratégie du gouvernement sur les
lithium sur l'industrie du lithium au
québec aussi
c'est vraiment serré sans savoir qu'il
ya deux ou trois semaines donc
donc il ya des choses a ajouté zhu et va
jouer exactement écoutez c'est tout pour
cette semaine la semaine prochaine on va
parler de la santé oms a parlé d'un
problème de santé important merci
alors y aura pas de surprise la semaine
français alors à la semaine prochaine
merci